and let's talk about some of the stuff
today announced and I mean first of all
I guess hardware Xbox Scorpio project
Scorpio coming holiday 2017 Rob you
impressed I am I'm amazed by this
I think they the way they pitched it has
been fantastic the main thing that they
were saying the key point is that any
xbox game can play across any Xbox
system a serious one the Xbox one s or a
project Scorpio that is the key point
now where the Sony can say the same
thing about ps4 K it remains to be seen
but I think that's a key point for
Microsoft the second key point and they
were talking about it in the video they
were saying this was designed for
developers and that's I think that's so
important the Xbox one's quite tricky to
develop for quite elaborate the ps4 has
been a massive success because mark
Cerny built a machine that was very easy
to develop right I think changing that
perspective making this as easy as
possible to develop for it's gonna be a
key thing for them so I'm super
impressed six teraflops that was what
the rumor was floating about about two
weeks ago you're talking about like a
three to four times you know you can
never tell unless we actually get the
games and start doing performance runs
on them but it's a significant upgrade
at this stage Mike um could they almost
call this a new console because you know
it's I guess the reason they probably
wouldn't is because then with the
backwards compatibility stuff or the
like constant cross compatibility that
messaging might get a bit muddy but it
seems like a pretty fundamental upgrade
yeah definitely I mean with all the
actual improvements if is like it's
purported to be three or four times more
powerful that's well that's like the
jump from a console to another
generation the slim in the meantime is
pretty big I mean that's $300 yeah it
doesn't seem to out of people's
ballparks I guess just like to fill that
gap e4 cuz holiday 2017 is sort of a
while away for this kind of announcement
I guess well maybe not for this kind of
announcement you know what consoles are
always rumored for a while but you still
have like ps4 0.5 or if it's called
that's gonna be announced you know in
the interim you see when they actually
release but like Rob had said the fact
that it's kind of this lineup of
consoles it's like this right ran now
it's not exactly they're not marketing
as a new console
despite the fact that from a hardware
standpoint kind of is yeah it's probably
the new frontier of consoles this
incremental sort of upgrades and it this
also sort of cleared up some of the
virtual reality stuff that came out of
Bethesda when they said hey we're
launching fallout 4 on HTC vive in March
I guess that's why they said that maybe
because we're not going to guess I mean
Microsoft didn't talk about virtual
reality at all the rumor was that they
were in with oculus so maybe you could
interpret that as ok all that stuff's
gonna come on Scorpio in you know
holiday 2017 we'll talk about that later
what's your read on that Rob oh it's the
big question is what virtual reality
device are they talking about they're
saying this console is but VR ready its
VR capable
no compromise is what they were saying
who's like bigoted Sony if you ask me
because Morpheus is quite a modest
mostly powered VR device they're saying
no compromises but the question still
hangs in the air what VR device they're
talking about are they talking about
oculus I like talking about vive how
they talking about both and yeah are you
my hololens have they even made that
decision yet
right who knows I'm not really
interested in the other but you know
it's quite an interesting point
yeah I'd say before the show you were
talking a lot about how you know it is
time for the xbox slim we did finally
see it it's got and they were talking a
lot about the 4k video which was rumored
beforehand and as a new wireless
controller with a textured grip higher
range Bluetooth same price as the
regular one and they also mentioned HDR
games what do you think about slim do
you think it's a decent stopgap between
this and Scorpio
whether you announced the slim I was
excited for it I thought okay maybe this
could be something I can pick up replace
my old giant xbox one but then at the
end when they announced the Scorpio I
was like what's the point now surely I'm
just gonna save my 300 bucks wait and
maybe an extra year deal with the Xbox
one I currently have and then get a
Scorpio yeah but for people who want to
get into Xbox one gaming I think it
would be a good stopgap because like
they said everything now works on
everything yeah they've really torn down
some walls here the interesting thing
about that 299 I mean it's basically
going to replace the Xbox now I don't
see what anyone would go for that looks
super slick as well and then the other
thing that they added I guess we should
throw in with this
is the customizable controllers in
design lab this is like the least
Microsoft ever like that people make
danke jolly what do you think about this
one Rob I'm like I'm really excited to
build my own controller how much would
you spend oh you would spend $50 right
now for regular asked one hundred and
fifty dollars for your eSports
controller what would you spend for a
pink triggers and a green faceplate my
line is $79.99 no you got to talk him
down start at 40 they're gonna try but
do you think it's gonna be a premium
price on this bike probably I would
spend like a hundred if I can get we do
yeah if I get like a lime green and
orange controller some things are some
gaudy awfulness yeah you can change up
the d-pad and my name is a bottom so I'm
guessing this works like whatever like
what were you saying like the mic that
Nike store in New York where you just
walk in yes I'm like the bigger Knight
like Nike town has those new labs you
can design every aspect from the swoosh
to the I can see every game Nike being
released as an Xbox one exclusive now
coming with a pre-order bonus of control
of skins though right yeah yeah they
just like pre-built I mean yeah unlike
stuff you can do online as well and like
Puma as well and a couple of other shoe
stuff so perhaps this is via a web page
or an app of some source I guess we'll
find out soon enough
okay let's get into the the other
interesting I guess another interesting
announcement we saw today was this this
the the walls of the software of
software wasn't been sort of like taken
down between PC and Xbox one we talked a
little bit about this before the show
started but this was pretty ubiquitous
across all the games they were talking
about Rob what was your take on what is
xbox is cross player what have they
called it again play anywhere play
anywhere anywhere wherever you want this
is part of Microsoft's continued efforts
to be more and more and more like Sony
and more and more and more like valve
right this is cross by cross play on
xbox basically it's a long time coming
I'm glad it's here I don't know how I
don't know how successful it's gonna be
I don't know how many people are in that
Venn diagram of Windows 10 fans and Xbox
one rights who want to play a game
between
PC in their console I don't know how
many of these people exist I think the
biggest problem they had previously with
this was that if you owned a PC because
the Xbox one was so underpowered that
you're like okay well if I'm gonna get
quantum break on both of these or any of
these again you'd be like no I'm
definitely playing on PC like I had I
played The Witcher 3 on xbox one and
then I built my new PC I have never
touched that again like you've never
choose one of the other and the thing
with the Sony stuff was that like it was
on ps4 and Vita and it made sense
because they're like two different use
cases for playing games right so it did
feel like an a leave added thing I leave
value added thing and so I mean lots of
games have this they were talking about
Gears of War was gonna be on that Forza
horizon 3 they've also talked about
cross save being sort of ubiquitous and
cross play then between a lot of these
as well so we had Xbox we had an Xbox
one folks playing with PC folks in Forza
as well it's it's a better deal than the
Sony thing right Mike cuz it's like
these are full price games it's not like
you know Vita I like my Vita but the
Vita you know yeah it's like guacamelee
and stuff yeah good game buddy games
mostly right ya know like this is you
buy gears before you have it on both
platforms like you said it's it makes a
little more sense to have one that's
like kind of a mobile thing and one
that's our handheld ones like stationary
in your living room and kind of odd that
it would be odd if like the PC and
consoles were just kind of you buy one
you don't have the other even though
that you're playing the same space but
it makes sense I mean if I get Halo Wars
to play it on my xbox depending on where
I am I can play it on PC it seems like a
really good deal it's not you're not
like spending for you know like two
different versions of the game likes
each time and the Shirdi not losing
money on this like this probably not a
lot of people who are like buying both
on PC and Xbox right until now they're
probably gonna get a lot of goodwill out
of it it's gonna feel like an Al you've
at every time you buy an xbox because
you know every person buy an xbox is
looking like oh all these games are
gonna work on it from their perspective
it encourages PC owners to check out an
Xbox encourages Xbox one owners to
upgrade to Windows 10 which much less
write anyone's yeah dudes good point
this is not gonna be Windows XP
presumably not gonna be Windows 8 it's
gonna have to be Windows 10 Amy
yeah it's not gonna be any of those
operating systems it's only in beyond
Windows 10 so I know it kind of makes
sense yeah good news